We’re going to let you in on a little secret.
One that’s maybe not actually that much
of a secret: sometimes, we don’t know what
we’re looking at.
We’ll find a microbe that looks familiar,
but the name of it eludes us.
Fortunately, we don’t need to know the name
of something to show it off.
So when these situations arrive, we’ll go
with a name that is as specific as we can
get, like the ciliate here that we refer to
so specifically as…”ciliate.”
But with our new differential interference
contrast microscope, we’ve been able to
make out all sorts of new details that we
couldn’t see before.
And in some cases, those new details have
helped us identify organisms that we could
not name before.
Like if you look closer here, you might be
able to make out this little bit of a crystalline
organelle.
That little tiny thing is called the organelle
of Lieberkühn, though it’s also known as
the watch-glass organelle because it resembles
a watch glass.
What does it do?
We’re not completely sure, though it might
be something related to phototaxis, which
is how you move toward or away from light.
But what it helps us do is identify what we’re
looking at and give this ciliate the more
specific name of Ophyroglena.
Ophyroglena is a genus of histophagous ciliates,
meaning that they feed on tissue.
The one we’re watching here has been drawn
to this crustacean like a shark smelling a
drop of blood in water, except it’s a microbe
drawn to a crack in its shell.
And once it gets inside, the ophryglena gorges
on the tissue inside.
So the Ophyroglena seems like it should be
easy enough to find.
We just need to keep an eye out for the watch-glass
organelle and other dead organisms.
But one of the reasons it’s hard to identify
these organisms is because they do not always
look like this.
Some ciliates have life cycles that take them
through different shapes, and sizes, and activities,
and responses.
It may be the same organism, but the way that
it looks or behaves changes.
Ophyroglena’s life cycle is made up of 5
established stages, as well as a few additional,
though more rare, possibilities.
The organism starts in its theront stage,
taking on an elongated shape as it swims freely
about the microcosmos.
It’s moving a bit quickly, so it might not
be very apparent, but at this point the watch-glass
organelle should be visible.
The theront stage doesn’t have food vacuoles
yet, but it still seeks food.
It’ll swim around for about two days chasing
chemical stimuli and light that point it in
the general direction of food.
But once they settle down into a more restful
state, they begin to fill up with food vacuoles
and move on to their next stage.
The Ophyroglena becomes more opaque as it
transitions into its equivalent of adulthood:
the trophont stage.
At this point, the swimming trophont will
still be drawn to light, perhaps to help hunt
down the same dead tissue these bacteria are
attracted to.
But as trophont gives way to protomont, the
Ophyroglena starts to change as well.
Some will still be attracted to light, but
others will be more drawn to an absence of it.
This one got stuck between some glass, but
with a little water added to the slide, it’s
back to moving.
Then after a few hours of eating, the protomont
will begin to slow down.
This is the protomont’s time for change,
and so it morphs into a tomont.
As a tomont, the Ophyroglena avoids the light
as it prepares to reproduce.
Some Ophyroglena species form a division cyst,
while others create and stay attached to a
sticky substance instead.
Whatever the venue, the result is the same:
the tomont divides several times to produce
anywhere from 4 to 8 smaller and rounder tomites
whose watch-glass organelle has now disappeared.
The tomites might form a chain that slowly
rotates for a few hours until it separates
into theronts, bringing the cycle full circle.
At times, researchers have observed deviations
from this typical cycle.
In some cases, the tomont might enter what’s
been termed the “migratory stage,” which
is noted for the largeness of the microbe
and agitated movement before dividing into
tomites or, in rarer cases, forming a cyst.
It’s not clear what conditions would cause
the Ophyroglena to enter this stage, just
that it’s a thing that happens sometimes.
Now, you might be thinking to yourself, “Boy,
we seem to understand all this really well.”
And honestly, the many lives of the Ophyroglena
would be its own business and we would probably
not know all of these things if it weren’t
for the fish problem.
In 1959, scientists at the Eastern Fish Disease
Laboratory at the U.S. Bureau of Sport Fisheries
and Wildlife reported that several of the
fish in their aquarium had died soon after
being infected with a ciliate.
The epithelium of the infected fish had sloughed
off and been marked with white spots.
With the right lighting and background, the
researchers could even see a mass of ciliates
swarming around the fish.
In their descriptions of the ciliate, you
can see the hallmarks of the Ophyroglena life cycle.
When active and feeding, the culprit had an
elongated shape.
And after dining on their course of fish,
they would become more rounded and descend
to the bottom of the aquarium.
This fish-feeding frenzy does not seem to
be typical of Ophyroglena.
At the very least, this report is the only
one we’ve found of its kind, though they
do have a documented history of infecting
insects.
But in the case of the fish infection, the
researchers compared Ophyroglena to the obligate
parasite Ichthyophthirius multifiliis, better
known as Ich or just Ich disease in fish.
The symptoms of both of these infections are
similar.
And Ichthyopththirius is a ciliate whose life
cycle has many steps in common with Ophyroglena,
including tomites.
The life cycle of Ich disease is formatted
around the fish the parasite must infect to survive.
And as such, the ways of fighting it are also
oriented around interfering with this process
of change and growth in the microbe itself.
Ophyroglena may not have the same infectious
mandate, but the parallels between their lives
and that of other disease-causing ciliates
shows why understanding life cycles isn’t
just about how an organism changes over the
course of its own lifetime.
It’s also about how those changes in turn
affect the world around them, as we all, even
the small of us undoubtedly do.
Thank you for coming on this journey with
us as we explore the unseen world that surrounds us.
And thank you, as always, to these people
on the screen right now.
If you like this show, these are the folks
you should thank.
They are our Patrons on Patreon.
They are the reason we can do this at all.
And if you would like to join them you can
go to patreon.com/journeytomicro where we
have a $2 and an $8 tier and they each come
with their own special perks and you can learn
more about that at patreon.com/journeytomicro.
If you want to see more from our Master of
Microscopes James Weiss, check out Jam & Germs
on Instagram.
And if you want to see more from us, there’s
always a subscribe button somewhere nearby.